e
est la hantise de certainss s s.
La certitude pour eux de ntsts
perturbées et de réveils
compliqués.
et conseillère, Bedaine Urbaine
- C'est sûr et certain
que d'adapter la routine
de sieste, ça, ça peut être
un défi. Ensuite,
qui peuvent devenir
un petit peu plus difficeses.
- Les conséquences sur
les tout-petits ne se limitent
pad'appétit et troubles de
l'humeur peuvent survenir.
- Et puis, ça peut même
venir jouer sur le système
immunitaire. Un enfant fatiguéàr
différents virus, là.
- Pour fai u un passage
en douceur, il n'existe
pas de recettes miracles.
au niveau graduel, à coups
de 10, 15 minutes
aux 2, 3 jours, puis encore là,
de voir comment l'enfant réagit.
- Chaque fululululululululululut
ressurgit : faut-il maintenir
cette pratique ou bien l'abolir?
- J'aimerais mieux rester
comme ça. Là au moououououououù,
après on avance,n n recule;
ras-le-bol, un peu.,,,,,,,,,,,,,
je trouve ça spapathique
aussi; ça rythme l'année.ôôôôôô,
je dirais.e e pense
que c'est beaucoupememememememe,
pour p g grand-chose.
- La Société canadienne
un avis sur la question.
JOSEPH DE KONINCK, membre
d'honneur Société canad. sommeil
c'est : cessons de changer
l'heure, gardons l'heure normale
comme l'humanité a évolué
et on devrait s'en porter
Il y aura moins de problèmes de
santé qui vont edédécouler.
- L'été dernier, elle a adressé
ses recommandations à Ottawa.
est du ressort
des provinces
et des territoires.
et le Yukon sont les seuls
à ne plus changer d'heure.
Pour sa part, le Québeconononon,
mais ne bougera pas
sisi ses voisins
ne font rien de leur côté.
ANDRÉ GRANDCHAMPS, astronomeo on
- À ce moment-ci,
ce n'est plus une question
d'effet sur les gens
ou de... d'une questio. . . . .u
une question politique.
- En mars dernier,
les sénateurs américains
ont voté à l'utitititititititit.
Mais pour devenir effectif,
ce projet de loi doit être
adopté par la Chambre
des repr
par le président Joeiden.
Le Mexique, lui, a décidé
fin octobre de ne plus passer
à l'heure d'été,
Ici Vincent Pichard,
Radio-Canada, Québe